I'm not going to lie the idea there
being a Bambi - I surprisingly found
interesting the reason I really liked
the first one I think it's a unique
important even groundbreaking film is a
movie that lets the art tell a lot of
the story it doesn't have to over
explain it doesn't have to create a bad
guy it's just a little slice of life the
sequel had an interesting premise at
least from my point of view it takes
place literally after Bambi loses his
mother
yes boiler alert I think most of you
know that though Bambi father request
that somebody else looks after him
because he's going to be too busy but
the owl suggests that maybe he should
raise him
thus the rest of the film is just
watching Bambi grow up with his father
who has never been a parent before again
no complicated stories no bad guys just
a little chunk of this one life in some
respects it's exactly what I was looking
for it's kind of what I thought I would
get kind of what I was expecting and
it's well done on the other hand though
it is a sequel being made years later to
something that was really unique and
always just kind of did its own thing so
the idea of trying to recreate it years
later does feel a little off it's not
something you can necessarily blame the
film for it's just kind of what the Neva
tably going to happen the artistry is
really good this movie does everything
in its power to recreate the look of the
original Bambi and the feel and the
pacing and for the most part it does a
really good job when it has to look like
calming winter it looks like calming
winters when those extreme colors have
to come in with the heavy shadows there
somehow
red and blue and so forth they bring
that back too and it's really effective
the backgrounds are never too crisp
either they're just a little blurred
again like the original film but seeing
how they're using artisan technology
years later you can tell it doesn't
quite feel I don't want the authentic
but a continuation necessarily you're
always aware they're trying to capture
the magic and the originality of the
first one and that never ever leaves
it's kind of like the sequel to 2001
it's not a terrible movie but the first
one was just so incredible and just so
amazing that you kinda know you're never
going to recapture
and that lingers over the entirety of
the film but on top of that there are
some other problems too one is there are
songs of the time period thrown in and
they are kind of distracting which again
not that like all the songs in the
original band e were timeless but each
really do kind of take you out of the
environment not hardly in bed or return
to Neverland bad but still noticeable
the biggest problem or maybe I should
say pet peeve is the father himself
played by Patrick Stewart now Patrick
Stewart is a perfect choice he sounds
just like the original actor he seems
strong and firm and yes this is a really
good actor but I guess the way I always
imagined the father was Stern and strict
and didn't really laugh that much and
didn't really show much Molnar ability
he was the leader of the force he
couldn't show weakness he had to be
tough all the time so I figured that
would translate over into him being a
parent and while that's what they're
clearly trying to do he does show a
little too much vulnerability he plays
it more like the confused parent the
fish-out-of-water not yuk-yuk or
anything like that but clearly he
doesn't know what he's doing and of
course eventually he lets his guard down
and he goes play with Bambi and has fun
and then he realizes oh he was supposed
to be Stern and strict and yeah it's
just kind of that thing it's not awful
it's just not how I imagined that
character there was so much more mystery
and strength to him when he only said
one or two things when he first sees
Bambi in the first one just stares down
at him and doesn't say a thing that is
so intimidating I thought that was the
father I was going to get but instead we
get lines like a prince doesn't whoo-hoo
a fringe does not
mmm-hmm a prince walked tall a prince
doesn't show weakened is it stuff you
imagined the mother from brave saying in
my opinion it would have worked a lot
better if they show Bambi as a child
with his father and the father is strict
and Stern and doesn't show much humanity
and then you cut two years later when
he's older then he confronts the father
about why he was so Stern and strict and
the effect it had on him that seems like
a time that Bambi would talk about it
but when he cracks out his father
because he thinks he's being too mean
and he's trying so hard to be everything
you want it's just
feels formulaic and of course the father
feels heard but can't show the emotion
but then he has to see something that
Bambi does that prove his worth and you
know it but again it's not done bad it
is still just sort of watching Bambi's
life and it's done very similar to how
the first film is a lot of playful
moments a lot of nice artistry a lot of
dark moments but a lot of nice stuff -
any problems I have are kind of nitpicky
for example there's this one deer that's
kind of a bully but he's not the villain
or anything it's just kind of a jerky
fragile kid and I think they're building
out that this is the bully that then
confronts him years in the future he
even says at the end one day we'll meet
up again and I'm thinking you didn't
need to make that connection I like that
this was just a jerky deer it's the
forest its nature predators it's just
kind of guests there's also a
particularly messed up seeing where one
of the hunters in the distance uses a
deer call and it sounds like his mother
mother
[Music]
I didn't know whether I really like this
or found it really silly but it is kind
of disturbing and uncomfortable but in a
good way so overall it is good it just
can't be the first one like I feel it's
trying to be but I really give credit to
the directors and artists and writers
for trying to be the first one they
didn't have to they could just thrown
some directed DVD light animation old
Bambi and thumper get in trouble and
just all sorts of bullcrap like that but
they do put in the good pacing they do
put in the character they do put in the
artistry they do put in the suspenseful
moment in some respects I didn't want to
know what happened to Bambi in between
those years it's kind of like finding
out what happened to Batman after his
parents died he'd kind of liked it being
a mystery but we got Batman Begins I
showed everything that happened and if
it's done well it's done well this is
kind of the same thing if they are going
to show what happened this is not a bad
version of it I think if you like the
first film and are a little curious to
see if this is a good follow-up you'll
get an actually okay flick you can tell
a lot of effort went into trying to
capture the voice of the first one and
it doesn't go unappreciated if you like
the first movie in or even the littlest
bit curious about how this one is I
think you might actually like it okay
step out into the meadow and take a look
you
[Music]